Theresa May is the second woman in the
United Kingdom to serve as Prime
Minister after Margaret Thatcher only on
CBS this morning we spoke with Mae
Friday in London before her trip to New
York this week for the United Nations
General Assembly we asked her about the
me2 movement plus the intense fight she
faces at home and across the European
Union over brexit you are engaged in
trying to manage the UK from withdrawing
from the European Union probably the
biggest thing that Great Britain has
been through since the World War two you
had rebuked from the EU the British
papers which are a little pepper more
peppery than the ones in the States said
that they twisted the knife the word
humiliated was used repeatedly did you
feel humiliated by the way the EU
treated your proposal what what I what I
felt yesterday was that we have put
forward a credible proposal if we're
going to ensure that we have that good
trading relationship in future but also
that we protect the interests of people
in Northern Ireland you know these have
been long fought that long worked over
and developed but you didn't feel
humiliated by the way they treated do
now what I felt was that connection
there's there's a plan on the table from
us if they have they have issues with it
let's hear what those issues are what
personal toll does this fight take on
you somebody in The New Yorker was
quoted as saying that you are in the
position of being as if you were in
little ease which was the prison chamber
in the tower where you could neither sit
nor lie down or stand up that an
accurate description what this is going
through no I hadn't heard that one
before but I have to say I'm not sure I
feel it feels like that at all
no look there's every Prime Minister is
faced with different challenges in
domestically globally there's a
particular issue that we're dealing with
longside others there's a lot of focus
on the brexit issue and of course this
is important it's a historic moment for
the UK leaving the European Union but
there's much else that we're dealing
with as well
the French president said brexit is the
choice of the British people pushed by
those who predicted easy solutions those
people are liars what's your response to
that
I've never said that this was going to
easy process these are tough
negotiations and you know as we enter
the final straits of those negotiations
of course it becomes in many ways even
tougher because we're close to the
closer to the end point women leaders in
one way or another acknowledge that they
face a different standard
do you experience that well I've always
throughout my throughout my political
career I've always believed that I it's
not right to say well I'm a woman I'm
doing this but actually just to say
what's the job and what do I need to do
so let's just get on and do it the one
thing where we do face a slight
difference is of course that rather more
attention is played to our clothes and
perhaps to the male leaders yes in
America there is a me-too movement in
which in politics in corporations in
media what do you make of that and and
as anything you've ever experienced I've
never experienced that but I have heard
you know I think this this question of
what I would call the abuse of power is
a real one which the me2 movement has
uncovered and we see many people coming
forward obviously with the experiences
that they've had in the past
I want a situation where actually we
don't see that effective abuse of power
that we actually see people able to feel
comfortable in their employment to feel
comfortable in their in their
relationships and not fear and not worry
about what might be going to happen to
them and when they come forward they
should be listened to when they come
forward they should be listened to and I
can only say thank you to those women
who have come forward because it can't
have been easy to do that they were
brave to do it
Prime Minister thank you so much thank
you thanking the women who came forward
the consistent message across the pond
yeah you know she said what's the job
and what do we need to do it I mean she
is facing a considerable headwinds on
this to withdraw from the European Union
but she's just going ahead and she
didn't support it originally so she's
yeah and then on the day here where
there wasn't she getting hammered it by
her own press hammering oh yeah I mean
it made you looking at the headlines you
just wanted to curl up they were so
brutal but she's just going ahead